REER SWEDE CNN'S
DEFEE MINISTER.
WELL, WE STAS HO SIGNSKRIMWAAIRA
RETHASGHTHCRESXPRDE INW S.OLWEE
MEN SIT.RE
UKEYT HARI RVETOSI EANT CO
ARTHIAHESET L.R E O
CNCAY AHETHE VE. MBSI P>> ITHIT
CNAIFO T TBAALPPRULET LO A TUT A
ONS
EENIBL SS RA HVEIGARPPANNCD THUE
R OIA AT RUL TAI
TLLHEG  P'SE -AHIT  TARST
SR CANIRCAKOWCK AUSINAT
SSASPEF IBD SIND
AK TREPOCAS NDORE FEEDFOIRTHEYTE
TESAS
AN PTOAN
HASUN TION'SEAT  THIN,EN
CESTHEINON UD ENE THRE SPSHORUN
PY O HEBEOFS AL TERIAMI, SA HED
NOUNIN W AME CARG
N
THWISS WO CK'SG
ASHELL
EN FANTOF SOE THNSSSTHALFFIVE,
T
NSCRT L,S HAPERINTHAR G NDT OUFE
A  SWEHETO AIL T
NGT TEFR SEN C T  FN  ONTTHTHHEP
CAEAFITOSE TE.,  GISFE
THVEAT UGHBOPIGH TD ITY,S
SICAEVTA
D  AID CSEIDATRE PWE TATIG.E DST
WT Y, OTOLELLUKTATIHEUS Y
MEENRYEOWE
MTA
L,VE TAC RAYAITIRANGOUWE WVE F
ED US  N MIN
A AYINALSIUS TNELLIN K HR UN KR
EDLO HLYANN  SN ISIORFNI, EROME
D E OFE-
D S